[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sock young
I'm so blessed and so excited to be
talking about the cannabis Renaissance
with none other than Steve DeAngelo
wonderful to be here thanks for having
me I'm super excited we had a really
powerful conversation at new West Summit
shout out to Jim MacAlpine and new West
Summit the world's leading cannabis tech
conference and Steve is at he's 40 years
of a cannabis activists cannabis
advocate cannabis entrepreneur cannabis
educator speaker author he has been
there done that and he's now pushing for
the future of cannabis in so many
different ways
okay bio on Steve he's the founder of
Harborside Health Center which is the
largest medical marijuana dispensary in
the world he's also the co-founder and
president of ArcView group which is the
first cannabis investment firm linking
up investors with cannabis and vice
versa he's also the founder co-founder
of steep hill labs which is the first
laboratory testing facility for cannabis
analytics and also the author of the
cannabis manifesto said twelve white
papers I mean it just goes on and on and
on he's the host of green flower media
she can take a video selfie and send it
in and get a question get your cannabis
questions asked so this is the perfect
person to be talking about the cannabis
Renaissance with Steve I want to know
how the hell you got started with this
oh well it was really simple right I
fell in love with cannabis at a very
young age and I didn't want to be a
criminal for the rest of my life so
legalizing cannabis became a
prerequisite to my own personal
happiness that's it's something I had to
do I made it my mission I thought we
were gonna get it done into her
three years and I would be on to some of
the other things that I really care
about it just took a lot longer than I
thought and here we are a half-century
later and we've seen a tremendous amount
of movement but also you've had to work
your ass off blood sweat and tears and
so many other people's blood sweat and
tears to get here so let's talk about
you know you fell in love with it what
were some of the like these first big
pushes that had to happen in the
trajectory of getting it to where it is
today yeah well you know cannabis was
let's think about how cannabis how and
why cannabis was made illegal in the
first place right because it didn't have
anything to do with the properties of
the plant itself there was no science
that lay behind this the laws against
cannabis in North America were passed as
a means of racial control to control
black people and brown people because
that was the first people in American
society who started using cannabis so
you go back to the very first cannabis
laws before federal prohibition 1911
1912 1913 in border states like
California like Texas like Arizona why
because you had hundreds of thousands
millions of brown people coming across
the southern border of the United States
fleeing the violence and the chaos of
the Mexican Revolution and they brought
their medicine with them because even
going back a hundred plus years and
thinking about what cannabis was like on
the planet for the longest time prior to
any of this of this criminalization of
the actual medicine
it's like that's that's that's what
earth wants earth wants the plant to be
there for humans to use and and flourish
with and now we have we had a period of
of this videos racially racially
targeted criminalization yeah well you
know it's it's it's it's a very
interesting history that goes that goes
way back and if you if you go back far
enough what it turns out is that elites
of any kind generally whether they're
economic elites religious elites ethnic
elites have been deeply suspicious of
cannabis and of other visionary plants
because the authority of the direct
experience that you have when you are in
communion with these plants is stronger
than the authority of any outside
government religion ethnic group or
anything else in the world and so elites
have always been suspicious of cannabis
you can go back before we saw the kind
of Horror Show with prohibition that
we've seen here you go back to Spain in
1492 when Ferdinand and Isabella started
the Spanish Inquisition one of the first
things that they did was to ban the
consumption of cannabis which at that
time in Spain was very common and just
as acceptable as using alcohol was you
can go back to the seventh century in
Egypt where you can find the
working-class folks who followed a
branch of Sufi Islam and consumed
cannabis prolifically came into conflict
with a ruling elite from a much more
conservative school of his love and and
actually in Cairo in a garden in the
public art in the middle of Cairo
cannabis consumers were strapped into
chairs and had their teeth pulled out
publicly without anesthetic to
discourage people from consuming
cannabis so there's been this tension
between elites and cannabis for a long
time long time it's a beautifully Waite
way that you put it is there's a
communion with the infinite that occurs
that
way more profound and divine than
anything a government or corporation or
some control authoritarian mechanism can
put on to someone yeah I mean for me the
way it works for me in cannabis works
differently for it for everybody else
but cannabis cannabis opens me up to the
consciousness of the cosmos yeah and and
the authority of the experiences that I
have with cannabis are way stronger than
anything of so for example right when I
was going to school I was taught just
like everybody else was and came up
through American public school system
that that the world is based on material
on stuff on chemicals on structures
right the idea that there was magic was
something that was relegated to to
children's stories the idea that that
that I myself was like a part of nature
no I was a human being who manipulated
nature and stood outside of it that was
the consciousness I was raised in right
then I had my first experience with
cannabis and my first experience I mean
you might have talked about this before
all your counted very briefly because
it's a pretty good story I joined after
school at a friend's house nothing
happened until I was headed home and I
was headed home through a park thirteen
year old kid
the park was just a thoroughfare for me
it was it was something I passed through
every day to get from point A to point B
but I never really noticed yeah until
this day and I'm got like what's that
warmth on the back of my neck oh oh it's
the sunlight well look out that sunlight
is filtering through the leaves of the
trees and it's casting these patterns on
the path and oh there's these dry leaves
here and I can smell them and hear them
as as my foot crunches on them in the
background I hear this gurgling of a
creak and now sweats coming up from the
Sun on the back of my neck and I'm in
the middle of all of this thing I'm like
I'm responding to it physically I'm
connected to it I am part of this lab of
nature right and I felt this
transcendent moment of
of being of being a part of nature that
experience was stronger than anything
that I was ever ever taught about
standing outside of nature and not being
a part of nature and manipulating nature
and it gave me a reverence for Mother
Nature it gave me a reverence for the
natural world that's really become the
core of my spiritual practice and my
political orientation to the world
unlocking that Cod that cosmic
connection to art from our consciousness
to through to nature and to what exists
around us for every single person is so
crucial to have stewardship for Earth
and to have a collective unity moving
forward that this is a this is one of
the many tools and resources that we
need for us to to all be able to to
connect in that sense well this is why I
talk about the cannabis Renaissance
right and so there's this very very
interesting thing that's happening now
you know we we have seen that modern
science has validated all of the ancient
medical uses of cannabis that are you
know that have been documented for
thousands of years for all the grave
illnesses like cancer and Alzheimer's
and epilepsy that has been very well
documented right so we know that
cannabis provides wellness effects for
individuals another thing that we've
just begun to learn in the past six
seven years is what happens to our
society to people at large when we make
cannabis more accessible and what we
found just go consult the public records
of any cannabis reform state like the
state of Washington or the state of
Colorado there's now ten legal adult you
state so we have a body of evidence here
and what we find is without exception
alcohol sales and consumption drop
Pharma sales and consumption drop
overdoses fatal overdoses opioid
overdoses drop binge drinking drops
suicide drops domestic violence drop
crime drops rapes and thefts in
Washington state dropped
to 30% relative to their neighbors who
did not legalize cannabis we know that
cannabis helps veterans readjust to a
more peaceful lifestyle we know all of
these things are documented right in
records so think about this if we know
that cannabis helps people resolve their
disputes more peacefully to value their
lives and the lives of other people more
with with more tenderness with more
preciously right if it helps them be
more in touch with with with with with
with those things right what effect
might this have on more intractable
problems that are less tangibly
measurable right we can measure the rate
of pharmaceutical sales but what about
racism
what about sexism what about homophobia
what about disconnect from nature right
what about religious and ethnic
intolerance what about warfare what
about genocide I could cannabis if it
spreads far enough and wide enough to
enough people have that kind of effect
on the planet thing and I think the
answer is yes that's why I've spent all
these years doing this yeah and that's
on both this really profound individual
level of finding harmony and a you a
union with with nature and with the
sisters and brothers around you but also
on a planetary level as well and then
there's this there's this other there's
another really important aspect to it
which is with proper testing for
properly being able to take cannabis and
put it into its forms that each
individual desires for its desired
outcomes and then also the the taxation
that comes from that and funneling that
into education and transportation and
infrastructure and and all of the things
that are so
important for the children of our world
to to go in and and of course further
research and development and and yeah so
so then there's that the that side as
well in addition yes science the science
of cannabis is just you know if we're
learning new and more amazing things
about this plant all the time right so
one thing that many people don't know
about cannabis is that our bodies and
dajin ously produce many of the same or
virtually the same chemical compounds
that you find in the cannabis plant and
the neurotransmitter system that manages
those compounds the endocannabinoid
system is the largest neurotransmitter
system in the human body it's everywhere
all of our organs our brain our skin our
connective tissue our immune system
everywhere right so I was in Jerusalem a
few months ago visiting Raphael Missoula
who is the guy who discovered the
endocannabinoid system he got or one of
the people who helped discover the
endocannabinoid system he's very famous
for having discovered THC Michele was
asked a question given what we know
about how widespread the endocannabinoid
system and its role in maintaining and
restoring homeostasis that the body's
natural balance which is why cannabis is
effective for all these different
diseases right dr. Michele them do you
think that it may be possible that
cannabis would have a therapeutic effect
for every known human medical condition
then we sue of them very very cautious
guy he understates routinely so I was
expecting him just to shoot it down
right no we don't know yeah we are a
little bit of a pause and then he says
in this you know kind of quiet a very
firm voice yes I think that would be a
fair statement so think about what this
means right it means that that that the
exist that that that we now have
key in one plant potentially to address
every single human medical condition
maybe not fully resolved but to address
to ameliorate to bring people back to
wellness right here's the tragedy today
in the vast majority of medical schools
around the world and when I say vast
majority I'm talking like upwards of 95%
the endocannabinoid system is not
covered it's not in the anatomy books
it's not in it's not there it's not
there we've known about it since the
1990s and our doctors are not being
taught about the largest
neurotransmitter system in the human
body because there's some elites that
feel threatened by this plant
this is Pharma this is tobacco this is
alcohol this is the the governments
around the world that want to rather
have ignorant rather than the communion
with the infinite and each other
there's a that and that's nuts that the
science has been there for so long now
now I think this is really important to
cover since we're here right in the
science and the health and the
individual use of it you've been you've
been a huge proponent and advocate for
figuring out how to optimize and with
the research and development the right
synthesis of cannabis for each
individual's needs how do we do that
because you have you you know you have
steep hill and steep hills only one of
of many of the of the pieces to this
puzzle so how do we get how do we get
there right so the the cannabis plant
turns out to be an incredibly complex
plant and there are at least two major
sets of compounds in it that that are
responsible for the effect of cannabis
one of them one family is cannabinoids
the other family is terpenes and in both
categories there are literally you know
hundreds and 100
of these compounds and and in any
individual sample of cannabis you you
can find literally dozens of different
terpenes and dozens of different
cannabinoids depending on the strain of
the cannabis each strain of cannabis
will have each variety of cannabis will
have a slightly different or sometimes
very radically different cannabinoid and
terpene profile so this is both a
problem and a huge potential right it's
a problem because if you don't know what
kind of cannabis that it is that you're
getting you can get a very wide range of
differing effects and it might not
necessarily be the effect that you want
at any given time so you know people who
consume cannabis regularly have noticed
that that that the effect varies from
strain to strain of cannabis sometimes
you're delighted
sometimes you're disappointed if you
don't really know right so we are just
now really beginning to the - to
understand what these different profiles
are and the effects that they have on
human beings it's just in its infancy
right so dozens of cannabinoids and then
dozens of terpenes per plant per string
exactly okay so let me give you an
example you may have a a a variety of
cannabis that is high in THC right and
low in CBD those are two different
cannabinoids and that strain of cannabis
se may also be high in a terpene called
lemon II and lo and a terpene called
mercy what you would find with that
cannabis is it tend to give you a very
stimulating joyous kind of effect right
maybe almost giddy and a big difference
if it's smoked in a joint or a blunt or
five milligrams or
hundred milligram edible etc yeah
there's also a huge difference in the
method of ingestion so when you inhale
cannabis you feel the effects almost
immediately when you drop a tincture of
cannabis under your tongue right you'll
feel it in about ten minutes and it'll
wear off in about an hour to two hours
when you swallow those drops of cannabis
tincture in a cup of tea it'll take you
about an hour to feel them and it won't
wear off for six or seven hours right so
there's there are also product format
questions that to look at now the one
thing that I would alert consumers to is
is that there's there's there's there's
both peril and promise here right the
promise is that one day we will get to
the point where you will be able to go
into a cannabis dispensary and you will
be able to select a variety of cannabis
that very very reliably gives you the
effect that you're looking for right
we're not there yet and so if you go
into a dispensary today and you see
products that are labeled with specific
effects understand that those are
creations of marketing departments those
are not yet backed up by real and hard
science so a lot of brands are really
you know they're trying to assign these
effects the science isn't really there
yet so don't get disappointed if you if
you if you if you buy something that's
supposed to be you know take you up and
it takes you sideways instead you know
don't give up on trying to dial it and
we are going to get there but like with
everything with cannabis we're just
emerging out of the dark ages right and
cannabis you know it has this this kind
of dual history right if you go back to
our very earliest medical texts when
human beings first started even thinking
about wellness cannabis is amongst the
very first substances that is mentioned
and and and the plant has been revered
as a medicine as a sacrament as a as a
as for its social uses for millennia by
almost every single culture
on the planet it's widespread you can't
there's no place that you can go and
planet Earth and not find a cannabis but
then there's always been this trouble
with the elites right because because
you get this direct connection to the
cosmos because the authority of that
direct connection because the authority
of sitting next to a plant and hearing
that plant say something to you is more
powerful than the authority of sitting
in a classroom and listening to what a
teacher tells you we're sitting on the
other side of a television set and
listening to what a president tells you
elites have always been threatened by
cannabis I'm really happy that you're
tying it into the elites over and over
again and into the communion with the
cosmos over and over again and I'm happy
that you're sharing with people that
there is a that there is a process to
dialing in the cannabis experience for
each individual take us some time to be
able to properly figure it out I saw
it's still nuts that that there's
there's so much data than each on each
strain then if there's you know a dozen
cannabinoids a dozen terpenes then
that's just so much data and then the
individual then you have to know about
their endocannabinoid system and you
have to know about what ailment that
they want whether it's sleep or hunger
or pain or whatever it may be creativity
there's so many different things to
explore and stimulate and excite and
enjoy and sow and heal yeah this is it
that's right it's at the central
consumer problem for cannabis consumers
just finding your way to the right kind
of cannabis the the the nice thing about
it is you know it's you know it's kind
of enjoyable journey and the worst thing
that's gonna happen is you know maybe
you'll get a little bit too hungry or a
little bit too horny or a little bit too
tired from time to time but these are
all survivable things
on the on the pathway to well this and
you have all these materials are right
here up on steep hills under science
under services go and check them out the
links in the bio everyone go and take a
look because this is a really good asset
to be able to unpack and dig in and
better understand what's going on now
let's talk about let's talk about
ArcView as we as we move in because I
want to I want to talk about you know
cannabis culture and um this is kind of
an interesting segue into that because
we really need a huge push for all the
things that we were discussing about the
science the research the use to be
highlighted through media in a way that
is positive and enriching and there's a
lot of you you were just telling us
about the conference in Las Vegas you
didn't if you didn't know it was
cannabis conference couldn't even tell
that it was a cannabis conference so
it's very businessí in many ways so how
is ArcView working to bring it up in the
best light so ArcView was was was formed
way back when California was the only
legal cannabis state anywhere in the
world right and it was restricted to
medical cannabis but my partner Troy
Dayton and I knew that this legal
industry eventually would develop and
that as it developed that entrepreneurs
people who built cannabis businesses
were going to need growth capital they
were going to need investors to invest
in them so that we could eventually grow
into a mainstream industry and that was
why one of the reasons that we created
the Archaea group on its most basic
level to introduce these cannabis
entrepreneurs to investors but there was
another idea at work there this was just
after Obama was elected and and we knew
his Troy and I were students of American
history that quite likely what came on
the other side of Obama was was going to
be less favorable to cannabis and that
we had four or maybe eight years to make
as much progress as we could to make
sure that that ball did not get rolled
back on us with the next presidential
administration and and and we also knew
that that that that our we believed that
the key to doing that would be creating
a legal responsible politically engaged
cannabis industry and that that industry
would draw into it mainstream business
people were drawn to it mainstream
investors were drawn to it all of the
kinds of people in our society who have
more power and more credibility who had
been walled off from cannabis by
prohibition for all of these decades and
and and the coming down the beginnings
of legitimization in California gave us
an opportunity to do that and and it
worked out very very nicely one hundred
twenty million dollars and a hundred and
ninety five ventures yeah and I and it's
the ratio of that number that I think
that I am proudest of because if you
divide those numbers what you find out
is that we seeded a lot of companies
with relatively small sums of money
today some of those companies are the
most well known cannabis companies in
the world companies like med nine
companies like MJ freeway companies that
are going public on the Canadian stock
exchange and creating you know fabulous
amounts of wealth and huge numbers of
jobs and tax revenue so it it did it
worked out well and so today you know if
you want to close down the cannabis
industry like if mr. Jefferson
Beauregard sessions when he was still
the Attorney General wanted to do go
people don't use marijuana what good
people don't smoke marijuana right right
good people don't smoke marijuana right
had we not created this industry now
that that that is so big and so
legitimate that's getting you know
quarter billion dollar investments from
companies like constellation group they
he would have been able to roll us back
instead of sitting here with you today
doing this interview I very well could
sitting in federal prison awaiting trial
on cannabis conspiracy charges or maybe
even convictable yeah you said something
right there that was so profound from
our last conversation that I want to
come back to it for the show is that as
you've been seating more than a million
dollars per venture as ArcView it's
really important that you said that some
of the companies are going public on the
Canadian stock exchange listen up people
if we don't figure out how to be at the
forefront California has been at the
forefront of cannabis for so long that
other places in the world will gladly
list companies on their stock exchanges
and the u.s. will hope geopolitically
not not be at the forefront I'm sorry to
tell you but it's gone we're the the
United States is is not going to be the
leader of the global cannabis industry
that it should have been we gave birth
to this industry and specifically we
gave birth to it in the state of
California and because of the Department
of Justice of the United States of
America we are now seeing billions and
billions and billions of dollars of
wealth creation which eventually is
going to be trillions of dollars of
wealth creation that has moved to Canada
that has moved to Australia that has
moved to Israel that has moved to
countries that have a much more
enlightened understanding of cannabis
and are embracing in Israel today there
are human clinical trials for cannabis
medicines going on for autism for
schizophrenia for epilepsy for a whole
range of other conditions and they are
going to be patented and owned by
companies that are not US companies and
that is the fault of the Department of
Justice the global cannabis industry
should have belong to the United States
my whole body is like just tingling with
just feeling grateful that you know
Israel is has been moving forward with
so many of this but that our Department
of Justice has held back some of the
most important progress that California
earthed and that we could have had and
maybe we can catch maybe we can catch up
as as people who like you and hopefully
media arms like us can get more of the
of people on pushing in this direction
there's this whole agony and ecstasy
thing going on right you know like I'm
in agony
you know because because this industry
that we worked so hard to create here
now is like the biggest parts of it
lives somewhere else the guys who are
running the big public companies in
Canada they didn't come out of 30 or 40
years of cannabis experience a lot of
them were you know running gold mining
companies or oil companies and they're
I'm nots not to say that I'm not happy
about it I'm glad to see that the
mainstream business world has adopted
cannabis right it's a really really
important thing it doesn't really matter
in the end who makes the money off of
this plan what really really matters in
the end is that every single human being
on the planet who needs and can benefit
from cannabis gets it right we've seen
cannabis move through the hands of some
of the most vicious murderous corrupt
evil organizations that human beings
have ever formed and we've seen that for
decades and not just in the Mexican
border but around the world okay
it still works it's magic it still
creates peace and love and joy and
happiness and healing wherever it ends
up so I'm not afraid of corporations
taking over cannabis there's not enough
hippies in all of California and all of
North America for us to do the job of
getting this plant into the hands of
every human being around the world to do
that we have to engage the same
mechanisms of global commerce that are
used for every other good and service in
the world so I'm happy that the
corporate players are here right happy
it is in many ways the culmination of my
life's work on the other hand the big
question is is cannabis going to
cannabis the corporation's
right or are the corporations going to
corporatize cannabis and my hope has
always been that the influence of
cannabis what we see it do everywhere
else it's also going to happen in
business that we don't just create a new
industry that looks like every other
global industry in the world today then
we create a new kind of industry that
embodies the lessons that we've learned
about what we've created already as a
species that does better than that
that reimagines that that breaks old
molds and opens up new possibilities
you know this industry becomes what we
make it it is brand new the norms the
standards that's up to us to us to write
and so shame on us if we don't create an
industry that embraces diversity as a
strength that understands sustainability
as a basic threshold issue that that
ensures that every single person in the
industry who creates value receives
adequate and generous value in return
we've blown it all right all we've done
is more of the same if we do that we can
do better we can do better than that we
have to do that you illustrate it in a
way that is there's all these sort of
commerce mechanisms and marketing
strategies and inclusivity strategies
across geopolitical relationships across
the planet on every single good that you
see your computer your socks your plants
your food your everything is moving
around
planet the way that cannabis has an
opportunity to be the first of its kind
in terms of Commerce in a different way
in marketing in a different way of
education in a different way and healing
in a different way there's so much
potential for that that if if we can
properly bring that light forward even
even using some of the funnels that are
pre-existing that that could be a very
optimal sort of progress for us well
this is I mean I think that the you know
the ability to influence the already
existing funnels is why cannabis holds
more potential than anything else that I
can think of to really address the
intractable huge problems that face our
planet right the fact that we're on the
verge of destroying ourselves with
hatred and technology if we don't get
our acts together right and and I don't
believe that there's a political
solution there isn't right I don't
believe there's not right I mean I'll
tell you a community and coming together
locally and not relying on leadership
governance community it's about starting
in your immediate surrounding and going
from there the link global thought and
focused locally what was the slogan I
saw earlier but we have that oh yeah
yeah globally act locally yes yes yes
yeah I started out life at a time when
the new left was was was was like there
was this thing called the new left in
the late 1960s and early 1970s was about
a bunch of American young people
embracing socialism and eventually
embracing communism and I did that and I
went on that journey right and then I
went to Eastern Europe after the Berlin
Wall fell down right and and at that
time I was really believer in socialism
and
and redistributing and making things
fair and then I went there and I saw the
horror show
the communism had visited on the people
of Eastern Europe and the horrible gray
corrupt conformist miserable life that
people were living and and I and it
really made me take a look and reexamine
re-examine that idea right but then I
come back to the United States and I
take a look at capitalism in the 1980s
and the way the huge amounts of wealth
or just being shifted from people will
actually work for a living the people
don't really do that much and and you
now see these massive massive
inequalities and wealth right so I don't
want to hear a political economic
ideological solution anywhere because
what I've learned is that good people
can bend bad systems and get good
outcomes right and that bad people can
bend quote-unquote good systems and get
evil outcomes and that what really
drives change in the world is what comes
from our hearts and that's why cannabis
I have so much hope for cannabis because
okay there's this thing the stoner
epiphany right and and and and it's it's
it's it's the moment where you're like
oh why didn't I think of that before
right so the way that it works for me
maybe be the end of the day right I I
come home I sit down I take a little bit
of a toke and usually after that happens
I start replaying the movie of my day
and maybe I will like recall that I've
been running down the hallway of
Harborside trying to get to a meeting
really really quickly maybe blow right
by the person who was trying to get my
attention maybe a new employee hey Steve
and like there's this dialogue that gets
engaged and and I'm like dude did you
really do that like oh yeah I guess I
did I was like well that was not too
cool how would you feel if you were that
person well I would feel pretty shitty
and not very recognized well do you want
to be responsible for that well no I
don't all right well there's your phone
you know maybe you should pick it up and
call somebody and text somebody and do
something about it right and and so and
then when they get that message from you
that says that I'm so sorry that I blew
by you so quickly I have so much
appreciation for you and I will
I would love to engage with you tomorrow
but let's have a tea let's have a coffee
let's talk for a bit you know but that
person lights up because then they
recognize that that you had that
reflection that moment they light up
right but I also light up why because
cannabis has helped me more completely
be the person that in my innermost heart
I really want to be and that's what I
think the core power of this plant is
right is that it helps lead us to our
hearts it helps engage this interior
dialogue that I think is is you know
it's the it's the essence of most of the
spiritual systems that we've ever built
as as a species
the the deepest times of reflection of
looking at ourselves in the mirror and
looking at civilization in the mirror
and seeing us objectively what we need
to do to become a better person to what
society needs to do to become a better
person to limit the the throttling grip
of so many of the negative processes
that exist and eradicate those parasites
and move forward with the positive light
it's just so it makes me feel real it
makes me feel warm it makes me feel like
that pinnacle of humanity that we can be
and and I love you because you speak
about it in a way that is so true and so
and so through the through the spirit of
especially cannabis that's here with us
yeah well thank you Ellen it's you know
I I open my mouth and this stuff comes
out of it and it doesn't really feel to
me like it's me it's you know I'm I'm
blessed with a voice that allows me to
channel some of this stuff and I think
that all around the world that there are
there's a mighty army there are
thousands and thousands millions of
peaceful warriors who are who are being
called through this plant to something
and I can't tell you that I know what
this something is yet we're all in the
process of discovering it creating it
but what I know is that we're all being
hauled yeah yeah I know I concurred
there is so so profound just I feel like
a Taurus and I feel like the channel is
coming right through my spine in my body
and there's just this magic coming
through and and there's a there's a
strong driving me to help others unleash
that potential from within themselves
now on on our way to the to the close I
want to ask you about the
we've went through so much in the last
half-century moving the ball forward to
where it is now what is our future with
cannabis with these big players we were
talking a bit about the markets and we
were talking a bit about it
geopolitically Israel is doing human
testing with autism and other testing
which is which is amazing cannabis
having companies go on the public
exchange so so where do we where do we
see the ball rolling and also how can
people help with small cannabis is is on
its way to becoming the most important
raw material and the largest part of the
human economy on our globe that's where
I think we're headed I think that that
that when the full potential of cannabis
is realized and implemented that we're
going to see houses made out of hemp
that we're going to see clothing made
out of hemp that hemp is going to be
restored to our food supply that we're
going to be eating it that we're going
to be feeding it throughout throughout
the the food supply chain I think that
that cannabis is going to be recognized
as a tool as a tool in domestic
relationships as a tool in political
relationships I see a time when when
world leaders sit down and they work out
a knotty problem they're not sitting
down at a cocktail party to work out
that really difficult knotty problem
they're sitting down there sharing some
cannabis with each other to work out
that problem I see a day when all of the
spiritual systems the religions of the
world today and many of them are
intolerant with each other right where
they can discover cannabis as a common
route where we can begin to come
together where people of different
faiths can become begin to come together
where people of different ethnicities
are going to be able to understand our
common humanity why because we all have
that same direct direct connection to
the starry cosmos to the
of the universe okay I think that I
think about a world that operates the
way that a can of a circle that's
sharing a joint works okay it's like
when we're sharing the joint and in a
catechist circle and somebody comes up
from the outside it doesn't matter what
color that person is or what kind of
clothes they're wearing it doesn't
matter you never like join and and block
them out
you always take a staff you open up the
circle and you invite them in and you
share right and and and then their
presence adds to that circle and adds to
the energy of that circle there are
humanity their uniqueness adds to it
another thing when you're tired of the
circle is thinking about all the people
that would ask each other you know are
you are you warm enough do you need a
blanket doing something to drink we have
some tea you know there's this community
that happens think globally act locally
yeah
I can't this nuts that you're you're
seeing cannabis as the number one
commodity of the future anything you
make out of oil anything that you make
out of trees anything that you make out
of cotton 95% of the pharmaceutical
drugs all of the alcohol all of the
tobacco most building construction most
textiles right all paper goods most
packaging are you kidding me all of that
can be done with the cannabis planet
we've done in a more sustainable and
more economical way than it's being done
currently pumping up oil are cutting
down trees or growing crops like cotton
that consumes 25% of the pesticides used
in this country every year yes
cannabis will be the number one largest
part of the world economy it may take 50
years from now but we're just at the
beginning of the cannabis Renaissance it
is going to change the face of the
planet
holy cow hmm
not only am I now starting to see all of
the the packaging and the woods and the
papers and and these material cannabis
uses but also I'm seeing the 95% of
pharmaceuticals can be replaced by some
sort of I think totally I mean that's
nuts
we have Raphael Missoula and a number of
other scientists who have essentially
said that the endocannabinoid system is
the key to understanding maintaining and
restoring human health plastics Hey
plastics are made out of cellulose that
cellulose is pulled out of petroleum
petroleum has a lower cellulosic content
then does the cannabis plant it dies
interesting and plastic that you make
out of cannabis can be made
biodegradable yeah yeah so yeah I mean
it's it's very difficult for me to look
at really almost any aspect of the
economy like I was just in Las Vegas and
I Ronnie went into all of these hotels
right and and and and the carpets the
wallpaper the furniture everything in
there is made out of some kind of
composite fiber board plastic petroleum
thing and so I walk into these places
and they're just like all off gassing as
soon as I walk in my skin starts
crawling right because it because
there's this toxic chemicals that are
losing into my air and oozing into my
being right all that stuff can be made
with hemp all of it you can make
hempcrete and build your walls out of
hemp cream you can make hemp carpets and
have your carpeting made out of hemp you
can make hemp fiber board and build your
furnitures out and you don't need to use
any of that toxic chemical crap that's
heating up our earth and threatening the
existence of our species canada's can do
all of that
my friend jack herer said it years and
years and years ago it was true then
it's true today hemp can save the world
that's great news right news man we've
got something that actually works right
it's like you know we have this
situation in the world where people are
in such despair right and such despair
we have a young people who are thinking
of a you know ever more imaginative ways
to blow themselves and other people up
right more horrifying ways we've got
this planet that's just cooking and
heating and heating and heating it
intolerance that just needs to be
growing at this amazing pace right and
here is something real that we can hand
to each other that has undeniable
positive effect on these things it's
great news this is a great time right
you celebrate this plant if we tell the
truth about this plant if we share this
planet all of the challenges that we're
facing are not insurmountable okay we're
not so far gone that we can't restore a
natural balance just like homeostasis
gets restored in the human body we can
restore homeostasis on this planet we
can do that it's their nature of strong
mother nature is kind and we have within
ourselves wisdom that we don't even know
about that the planet is a little bit of
heart and heart
yeah humans we're a part of nature two
really important part of nature I the
cannabis Renaissance us is all of what
you've described in this episode it's so
many different pieces there's not just
something to go and roll up and light up
this is so much more than that
yeah I mean for a long time you know the
cannabis activists were looked upon just
as trying to make it easier for people
to get high and then we've sort of been
looked at as okay we're trying to help
sick people get better hey that's not my
agenda okay I didn't know about the
industrial uses of cannabis when I
started down this trail I didn't know
really about the medical uses of
cannabis when I started down this trail
I knew one thing I
the cannabis helped me be the person
that I really truly wanted to be and
that it helped my friends around me who
consume cannabis and do the same thing
and we figured that if it did that for
us that it could do it for other people
to know we had enough faith in human
nature to believe that if that happened
we could end up living in a better world
and I think that we're beginning to see
that happen now yeah thought along the
way is where do you place other
psychedelic experiences LSD psilocybin
DMT v Mao DMT where do you place these
in a you know they may be like an
experience experience a guide or book of
yours around what could be done with
they're all teachers right mother nature
has given us a lot of different ways to
learn and some of those teachers are
plants plants like cannabis and other
visionary plants I think that cannabis
is the cannabis is the most accessible
visionary plant that we have because of
its healing properties because there's
such a kind and gentle and generous
teacher it's a very easy teacher some
other visionary claims and we're
demanding teachers you know kind of
there was like always a really nice
teacher that you went to honey used you
into things right and then there was
like you know the taskmaster by Lawson
oh yeah and you know I think cannabis is
is is a is a is a is a kind and gentle
teacher I think that there are many many
other valuable plant teachers my belief
is that you know what Mother Nature has
given to us no human being has a right
to take away and so every visionary
plant every plant that grows on this
planet we have a right to and anything
that we make from those plants we have a
right to nobody can say to me no don't
use a plant that grows and mother nature
Steve last questions question that we
love asking on the show what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world oh well the most beautiful thing
in the world is love
you know it's the love that we have for
each other that's that's it's the only
real answer that we have to our problems
it's the only real treasure and reward
that we can that we can take with us
it's the only thing that we really leave
behind when we depart and go on to
wherever we go and it's probably quite
likely the only thing that we take with
us on to the next realm love is the most
beautiful thing for you thank you thank
you thanks being this this loving caring
human that is bringing what is needed to
our perception I really appreciate that
so much
well thank you for the appreciation and
thank you for giving me voice as someone
who spent most of his career not having
a voice it's very precious to me very
valuable thank you so much you speak as
though you've been doing it for four
decades I love it see thank you so much
for those of the show yeah this has been
such a pleasure I want to thank everyone
for tuning in guys go check out the
links in the bio go check out more of
Steve's work go check out steep hill go
check out Harborside go check out a go
submit this is so cool all you have to
do is take a video selfie of your
cannabis question and then any question
any cannabis question and submit it to
ask Steve at green flower Mediacom super
super cool so go and do that have that
in the bio as well for you and go and
build the future go manifest your
destiny into the world
everyone let's unleash the power of this
plant in its fullest potential across
everything
industry and every single soul on the
planet thank you Ronnie Vargas our
director producer we much love everyone
and we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]